Roger I have to ask you on a scale of
one to ten how excited are you about the
return of Rebecca Lowe oh that's
absolutely off the charts Dave I mean
it's to come back with the Premier
League without her hosting it because
she's been away in Rio doing a
phenomenal job it's a little bit like
traveling all the way to Marie only to
find that Khaleesi is out in the
countryside roaming around with their
dragons it's been very hard to watch the
football without her she returns next
week although white the great
commentator returns from Rio and I think
all will feel right with the world one
of the great free agent signings in the
history of the United States she is a
treasure as is Neymar for the host
country of the 2016 games how special
roger was that moment for him for that
country and for the sport drilling home
that gold medal winning goal breaking
down in tears I think it's an incredible
relief I mean the i was there in 2014
during the world cup in brazil which was
meant to be a coronation for the nation
for that team they were they believed
that God had selected their squad and
they nothing could stop them from
winning it they came unhinged in the
semi-final and got absolutely
eviscerated 71 by Germany just a night
of national tragedy in morning this win
over the weekend when they won the
Olympic gold will will not heal that the
Olympic tournament it's like the NIT to
the World Cups March Madness the two
tournaments they're not equivalent yes I
think there was an incredible relief
mostly because Brazil had never won the
olympic tournament and under-23
tournament its young kids and it's it
doesn't have the standing of the world
cup but it really annoyed them that they
had never won the Olympic gold so they
really wanted it he wanted it he wanted
to bring kind of a happiness to redeem
himself in the eyes
the Brazilian public and I think they're
still haunted by what happened to
brazilian football over the past decade
where it's gone from being the gold
standard to being a little silly but I
compare this victory the happiness of
the weekend and the gold medal to losing
in the final round of The Bachelor but
somehow finding love anyway with the
local accountant and living a very happy
in joyous life that's probably what
winning this gold medal was the greatest
equivalent to four for Brazilian
football and that's why the men in
blazers is a must watch comparing an
Olympic gold medal to the runner-up on
The Bachelor it is interesting animals
gimme goal in that situation can
completely change one of the most famous
players on the planet their legacy
almost but we'll see a burial narrative
is everything and that is certainly the
case with the Premier League Dave and
the Premier League is back and if I had
a toy gun a year ago that leicester city
at a five thousand or one shot would win
the title you'd have told me what I
would have told you that i picked
leicester city to win the title for the
past 123 years and it's never quite
worked I would have told you you're a
madman it's I mean that the joy of
leicester city winning the title I think
the greatest legacy may be in giving
false hope to all sports fans now a part
of you Cleveland Browns listeners I
think every single sports fan in every
single sports league now things that
they can do a Leicester City but it was
a remarkable story it was like a I mean
it's going to be a holy words it's like
a Hollywood movie it is going to be a
Hollywood movie a bunch of retreads
rejects journeyman kind of young hopers
coming together forging this absolute
collective sheer Brotherhood with with
with a style of playing a deeply
reactive counter attacking style that no
one could stop but I'll say the new
season has started Lester lost their
first game to possibly a team that will
turn out to be the worst team in English
football a pub team whole city they drew
that we
and already it's looking as if their
title defence oh that though a little
bit I believe like the footballing
equivalent of the bomb and the band who
let the dogs out in two thousand but
turned out to be a one-hit wonder what
more moves on who let the dogs out that
must be a tough act to follow though
when you survive relegation the year
before you come back against are
insurmountable odds are one of the
greatest stories in the world in sports
the emotional high of that almost
naturally leads to a low how tough is
that to follow that act I would say it's
incredibly difficult because when you
come in the top for the English Premier
Li you qualify with the best teams in
the world the Barcelona's the Real
Madrid's to Bayern Munich's and you
qualify for a second tournament called
the Champions League to this tiny little
team in an obscure town in England best
known as the potato chip capital of
Europe suddenly instead of playing in
obscurity suddenly playing in a suddenly
playing in the great chances of European
football and that is going to absolutely
destroy them they're not just playing at
the weekend that we play on Tuesday and
Wednesday they have a second front of
battle secondly there's no surprise
about them this season I mean everyone
knows what they're going to do everyone
knows how they're going to play and the
room manager a wonderful man Claudio
Ranieri he summed up their chances of
defending their title he said there's
more of a chance of ET landing at
Piccadilly Circus unless they're
defending the title so we're grateful to
them for giving us an incredible
seabiscuit sporting moment that I will
never forget that I think captured the
imagination in many even in America this
season there's so many teams so much
money so many new faces too much
rearming has gone on that it's going to
be one of the most competitive Premier
League's of all time and speaking of so
much money no one has more than
Manchester United they bring in a
special one how much fun will you have
with the new faces at
I just United what are your expectations
with them so the Manchester United
listeners they're owned by the glazers
of tampa bay buccaneers fame or in
famous owners probably Manchester United
a giant a mega Bram the global leader
who kind of lost their way over the past
five years since their Vince Lombardi
equivalent sir alex ferguson retired
after a couple of decades they went and
pulled in a new manager a winner Josie
Mourinho if you can imagine like this
pat riley and Bill Belichick had a
bastard Portuguese offspring he would be
it it is a winner is his winning is
inextricably connected to other teams
particularly Chelsea the Blues of
Chelsea so seeing him at Manchester
United it's just hard to to the eyes
he's like the Grisha is the greatest
defector to the Reds and Edward Snowden
and they've spent a huge amount of money
breaking the transfer barrier to pull in
a young potent star the bombastic Paul
Pogba less assigning more a statement of
intent they've spent a fortune on a 34
year old self mythologized goalscoring
wonders Latin Ibrahimovic and already
six points two games one they're looking
like the early leaders in the clubhouse
we eagerly await this premier league
season and with references to the
bachelor and to who let the dogs out and
to ET and many more that's why you have
to watch the men in blazers tonight
eight thirty eastern on NBC SN it's an
awful television show one last quick
thing a fantastic American story thus
far they seated young Californian Lyndon
Gooch playing for an unfashionable team
Sunderland and has been on a terrible
team a tenacious Terrier a great new
young American to watch this season
going forward something that primarily
could certainly use draw some interest
up here that is outstanding some
American
making its way over to the Premier
League eight thirty eastern time as the
men in blazers catch the podcast as well
on iTunes Roger Bennett thank you so
much sir we appreciate the time thanks
Dave and thanks to pulp at stake Rock'em
Paul PAP struck on the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience